[Music]
in case closed news case closed so we
devised a smoke alarm beep yeah
any new batteries burn they can serve it
by replace it and it still does issue
yeah it's against the [ __ ] probably
better probably I used hot dog napkin
help crack a 26 year old murder cold
case used hot dog napkin yep there's DNA
on em oh [ __ ] yeah nothing we're done
ladies and gentlemen
next episode was the weekend scrambled
into other topics yeah it's off the
record
hey 40 seconds nope yeah
Sam okay that's the other we can
scramble anyway all right dude he's a
hockey dad
his name is Jerry he was tracked by
prosecutors like he was tracked by
prostitutes
sorry not frosted I was gonna say
prosecutors but that doesn't make sense
by police officers Oh
our detectives write investigating this
and so they followed him to a hockey
game and after he ate a hotdog he wiped
his mouth with a napkin threw in the
trash they waited till the coast is
clear from the napkin and tested it with
like his DNA right and so with the DNA
that was found at the scene of a crime
of a murder back in 1993 there was a
stabbing of this woman named Ian and Dan
Han Oh bummer maybe too bad about the
murder too bad better name Saul and
g-man hey KD d G knee there we go she
was 35 years old and she got bartered
dirt she got murdered
yeah the back of n Jerry was 27 years
old and there were saying that this
killing was especially violent because
there were even stab wounds in the body
after she died like she was already dead
and he kept that how do you how do they
know I don't know I was wondering that
yeah and then so it turns out this fool
left his DNA all over the place she came
all over he did she was a prostitute
apparently it's always the prostitutes I
know why he or I know how he did it he
probably killed her and then he raped
her and then after he was done raping
her she had rigor mortis and it freaked
him out aah he [ __ ] stabbed her while
he was having sex he was stabbing her
[ __ ] that's really no no what happened
after this after he killed her
police were called to the building
because a tenant saw water coming from
the apartment and that's when police
found her dead body in the shower
wearing only socks and the water was
running and so she had dozens of stab
wounds oh so you did it at her apartment
yes other pictures in like the woods or
something
no no her apartment sorry did I mention
that no I didn't my brain was just going
a while um yeah so then they were saying
that they were there was DNA on the bed
comforter a towel and a washcloth any
shirt that had a blood stand it note
that was also lifting on saying
everywhere there was blood and come I
guess blood and oh yeah his own blood
he's bleeding too baby
yeah that sucks man so then they had
they collected the DNA but obviously
like you know they couldn't link it to
anyone because he just got away clean
and he wasn't a suspect or anything so
then um that's when they revived the
case back in 2015 and then they sent it
to a state Bureau of Criminal
Apprehension or BCA
and then also a private DNA company and
then that's when the if FBI ran the
sample through an online genealogy
website last year 23andme don't do that
can get you yeah and so that's when
someone related to him submitted DNA to
these website or one of these websites
and then that's when they were able like
it it's like you know alerted yeah
authorities like hey there's a match
here and so they were able to pin it
down or like narrow it down to this dude
followed him to that hockey game that's
all been doing Gucci they're gonna get
you damn that's pretty crazy that is
nuts
how many other people did he [ __ ]
kill that's what I want to know
I know cuz if someone is that crazy
where they [ __ ] the [ __ ] out of someone
kill them it's not the first things not
the first I've seen the Ted Bundy tapes
I know I'm gonna know I'm an expert at
this too and I know that when you have
extra violence against someone that you
have killed you it's probably personal
you probably newsperson yeah right but
not just like hi I'm gonna [ __ ] you and
kill you now look but like uh-oh
pretty much it yeah maybe he was like
like her number one customer regular job
and he wanted to like that come on I
could save you oh if you was like Ted
Bundy then he developed a fetish for
horror sex horror sex yeah like scary
sex or like like body mutilation insane
oh no never called horror so I just made
that one no like [ __ ] nipple rings
with plants like a memory sort of thing
but yeah he developed that fetish
because I guess like it was really
popular back then weird or was like
horror movies and then there was always
this damsel that was like oh no then she
gets killed and [ __ ] and he started
associating that with like sex so then
that would get him off and you would
obsess and he was like [ __ ] now I really
want to kill somebody in like have sex
with them yeah I just want to try it
yeah so he liked it this is Jerry you
gotta keep doing it he looks like a
crazy mofo it's dead behind the eyes
deal right he killed genie before he was
married before he had any kids
so afterwards he attic so he was lucky
oh I gave that up I'm gonna clean up
those straight narrow mrs. genie
and she looked kind of scary though she
looks scary - yeah it was like a flop
yeah
because cuz the hair oh yeah poor lady
Oh would you tell your parents like
blues you feel like your they were just
like hey by the way like we found all
this like extenuating evidence that's
like hey your parents are actually like
serial killers I've been like that
explains a lot [ __ ] pretty huge
that explains a lot
for you yeah hell yeah I'd be like I did
this I mean that's close enough much if
I found out I'm like I wasn't really
changed too much if you haven't seen any
other tendencies like other serial 10 do
you think that would be like a
compartmentalize a separate thing from
like the life and like memories and
stuff that you knew from your for yeah
because I still feel like people have
choice so I'm like all they chose to put
that behind them and they just want to
be regular but it's like I had other
memories of every time my parents beat
my ass they pulled out like a guitar
string like they wanna fry on my neck or
something I ma'am
no no no I'm keeping tight go away from
me you know that thing that you set up
in genetics or something like how a
person is when they make a baby the
state so epigenetics is the state that
you are in when you reproduce you pass
those genes on what if one of your
parents was killing during that time
that you were mean the things change in
your mind no wonder you know because
I've never killed anybody
yeah I know but then what if you had
some deep thoughts and that start to
surface you're just like oh my god but
there's also free will
yeah that's right there's also free will
and choice so I haven't I haven't killed
anybody I don't think they're something
oh that's cool would you still love your
father
yeah okay big of you Thursday isn't that
in the situation yeah yeah cool cuz this
guy that I yeah just so it's it's
actually an interesting question right
is it depends on your childhood right
like if you had a badass childhood
you're like what I could never believe
that man thanks for the [ __ ] bouncy
room
birthday like like the children about
top over again yeah yeah twin girls and
then they you tell like according to
testimonies and [ __ ] these girls have
their own guns like they're only like
cute ass little pink gun and stuff she
was like I guess you could see it from
one way but then knowing the stuff that
they're accusing him of I'm like
Escobar's son is super interesting like
he he talks about how his dad was this
huge criminal but then he's like but I
also loved my dad so has this weird
thing where he's like I know what made
about my oldest she thinks my dad didn't
is [ __ ] insane but then I was just a
kid like a little kid and I loved my dad
and he's providing and he was like being
the best father like for his and the kid
texts or ever play soccer on the TV show
right but no they love you and it's one
of the cooler crimes it is because if
your dad was like a petal that's like
what you yeah like what couldn't you be
a different criminal dad like why you
gotta be that one but Escobar was also
murder is a big time like like Lawrence
getting what he did the Parliament Shin
like walking through the courthouse
[ __ ] dude what they I mean with that
kind of murder still kind of like
glorified not like this this is like
serial killer
that's a little different you're the
kind of movie sexy though unfortunately
well this one this one's like psycho
killer yeah I think Escobar has that
like I'm a gangster Scarface appeal
yeah there's like that's a different and
it's not and it's horrible because it's
like the same thing they are cycles like
in their own right because the body
count on one end is like way higher but
um it's like the association with like
the the Grossman of it is like totally
different well they also weren't
standing into their eyes and jerking off
in their bodies that's true stuff there
was no Escobar was paying all the people
to do it or maybe he take the gun and
[ __ ] pop somebody but he he wasn't
like he wasn't the one going to the
court and shooting all the judges and
[ __ ]
I guess he's paying that [ __ ] yeah but
he was still his hand had still him I
think it's just asthma cop but it but
it's that's how people are we're all
weird
yeah poor things it's just a macabre -
I'm sorry
I'll be like well thank you for not
doing those things to me and giving me a
best childhood that you taught you could
possibly try to give true if that was
the case there's a man called the Iceman
he had two kids that he never beat did
any of that but he also killed 200
people for the pony oh yeah I saw a
talking man but he would never lay a
finger on his children he loved good
they had that weird
honor code yeah such a strange thing
like I kill 600 people for the mom but
never my children yeah exactly
you say you even kill his wife or is
like wait I remember talking he wouldn't
kill his Jill did we talk about him on
all times or he'd like like his son hits
a baseball and breaks the neighbors
window and he makes his son go to the
neighbor and apologize and say they're
gonna fix the window but then he kills
sooner people for the mom [ __ ] like that
it's just like wow
[ __ ] yeah people's brains work I thought
he would take his son over
and then tell then beat the [ __ ] out of
the neighbor for having a window that's
even breakable right you think that we
trying to teach your son right all [ __ ]
is that crazy weird code stops with him
yeah yeah pretty cool pretty damn in a
different world
[Music]